hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
I am joined by my compatriots son of
obsession how are you Sona hi you seem a
little prickly today about something I
don't know what's going on but we'll
find out soon what are you talking about
and um Matt Corley Hi how are you Matt
I'm pretty good how are you I'm doing
very well you okay yeah you okay yeah
okay I never seen prickly you came in a
little hot today I didn't know what was
going on I think she's responding to you
yeah you said I you said I was the
dumbest person you ever met yeah before
we started recording
oh yeah you're right wait a minute I'm
thinking and you said no I meant the
worst person I am that's right right
yeah so I corrected it you're not the
dumbest you're the worst yes so why
would that get you all
um
[Laughter]
hey stupid but how are you in general
how are you I'm good yeah I'm fine you
know I was checking my wound it's fine I
cut my finger cutting zucchini but I'm
okay it's fine making what uh I was just
roasting zucchini
a mandolin and I sliced a piece of my
finger off because it was fine do your
kids eat all kinds of food are they
super picky they eat all kinds they do
it's amazing well it's just because we
just you know we're we give them a lot
of ethnic food and then they just eat a
lot of them we tried that with when my
kids were little especially my son's so
picky super suspicious that everything
was poison would only eat very specific
things but I've been when I've been
around you they're eating everything you
just like can pull something out of the
lawn and they'll eat it it's incredible
and we do sometimes we just go out there
and get something and just put they
often it's just grass yeah which is
weird I don't think there's any
nutritional value put enough spices on
it it's fine they just look like kids
that eat everything they do they eat a
lot I mean but Becca eats now okay we
don't use his name on this podcast now
we put his name many times it's never a
lot of times never yeah his name's Rick
his name's Rick yeah
I wish this is Rick O'Brien my son
I think I had a pretty good save there
yeah pretty solid but Rick if anyone's
mad at me they'll be like where is that
Rick O'Brien
um no no he's he's good but I'm seeing
as little kids yeah I was very picky
eater I was very very picky which
doesn't work because it was one of six
there's kids there's a bunch of kids in
my family and I was one of six you
probably got food hand-me-downs yeah I'm
like this doesn't this hamburger doesn't
fit me yeah this hamburger the hems on
this hot dog are too long none of that
makes sense it's just stupid apologies
all around but the point I'm trying to
make is that I remembered once saying to
my dad he was serving us all something
you know putting it all on the table and
I said don't you know
like this and my father said why would I
know what you like or what you don't
like
oh my God and you know what oh my God he
said why would I know what you like or
what you don't like and look I'm not
putting my dad down because I actually
think he's has a point I think they're
going to call you Rick yeah listen here
Rick you're gonna shut up
and you're gonna eat that God
marshmallow and potato sandwich in an
increasingly competitive job market it's
important to make sure your brand stands
out from the crowd that is important
Sona yeah that's right vegan cupcakes
from your kitchen or marketing your
wedding photography business I'm just
making these up yeah I can tell
Squarespace helps you create a modern
platform through engaging and
aesthetically pleasing online presence
that's important if things look nice
people will buy with member areas you
can unlock a new Revenue stream for your
business and free up time in your
schedule by selling access to dated
content like videos online courses or
newsletters newsletters yeah stand out
in any inbox with email from Squarespace
email campaigns collect email
subscribers and convert them into loyal
customers social display posts from your
social profiles on your website
analytics you want to hear more I'll
give you some use insights to grow your
business learn where your site visits
and sales are coming from and analyze
which channels are most effective good
heavens and alert above head to
squarespace.com in for a free trial when
you're ready to launch use offer code
Conan to save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain I appreciate the
honesty because I think maybe my dad was
that way but also would never have
admitted no no my this is a rare moment
of Candor from my father and he was kind
of just saying
there there's six kids there's a bunch
of animals running around the house like
pets dogs cats my brother Luke had
parakeets your grandmother lives with us
um and your both parents work full time
and then suddenly this kid with an
orange bowl haircut is saying don't you
know this isn't my favorite ripass and
my father said what I barely know who
you are
shut up open your Gob and shove it in
but what were you thinking he would just
go make you a special meal that was
different from everyone else's I think
for a second I I just you know whatever
was put in front of me was like no I
don't don't you know I don't eat
swordfish
don't you know and I you know this was
the 70s Nixon was resigning uh you know
what it was a tough time
appetites Across the Nation oh okay yeah
I think we were all just on edge about
inflation and what's Ford going to do
and what's this new show starting out
live oh Chevy Chase left will the show
ever continue and that was the mood of
the times and then here I am saying I'm
not sure this fish is my favorite father
father
hello
ding ding ding ding ding I had a spoon
and I was banging on a cup that said
yeah it said Nixon in 74 and I'm like
ding ding ding ding ding
oh God it's probably real
Todd is not
cold not fried and he was like what shut
up eat it I don't even know which one
you are
which one are are you even one of ours
are you a boy are you a girl
are you one of the pets
all these questions he's asking him out
loud and I'm like well first of all as
we can all tell I'm all boy
second of all I'm the one we call Conan
third from the top and fourth from the
bottom
then neighborhood bullies came in
through the window in my own house and
beat the out of me oh my god father
father help me I would have been one my
father was like here's 20 bucks kidding
hit him again I think this is truly the
first time I felt pity for you
I actually feel for you really yeah that
guy I just did yeah because it felt real
it felt like God yeah your dad didn't
know what you did or didn't like come on
I saw pity for his dad yeah and I do
want to I I do love my dad and he's a
great dad and uh it's still to this day
a great dad but yeah did he think
constantly about what my desires were no
because it was a different time it was
The Depression
no yeah for me the depression includes
part of my first 10 years of my life my
depression goes from 1929 to 1979
because it includes my depression as a
child anyway we got a lot to talk about
yes yes we'll pick up more on that
father
toilet seat on the third floor
it's vinyl and that's not how I like to
ride
and you know that father
you report that hey Poor Dad